let's see if we can name this guy right
over here and so like always we always
want to look for the longest carbon
chain or the longest carbon cycle and I
think it's pretty obvious from this
picture that we have a very long carbon
cycle here that we can start or we can
just look at this we have one two three
four five six seven eight carbons in a
cycle right over here and so we can call
this backbone which is the backbone of
our molecule right over here this is
cyclooctane cyclo cyclo octane it's an
octane in a cycle it's an alkane because
it's all single bonds right over here so
that is cyclooctane now let's think
about the different groups that are
attached to this to this backbone right
over here so first we can look at this
one right over here and we could ask
ourselves well how many carbons are
there how many carbons
well there's one two three four carbons
that are attached to the backbones
so our prefix phone we're dealing with
four carbons is butte and it is in a
cycle so this is a cyclo beautiful
beauty o butyl and we also have another
cyclo butyl right over here so this is
another cyclo butadiene beyou I'm
spelling it cyclo beauty
group now let's think about let's think
about this one right over here how many
carbons are there we have one two three
carbons so our prefix when we're dealing
with three carbons is proq and they're
in a cycle as well so this is a
cyclopropane propyl group and now we can
jump over to do these two groups right
over here we see that these are clearly
the same groups
let's count let's count the number of
carbons they have well we have one two
three four carbons so if we're dealing
with four carbons we would think about
the prefix Butte
but this isn't in a cycle and it's not
in just a straight chain it has this Y
shape and so the common name when we end
up with this Y shape when we're attached
down here and then that's we're attached
to one carbon here and that's attached
to kind of this this this this this
carbon right over here this isn't
attached to these other two this is an
isobutyl group which we've seen multiple
times before ISO butyl isobutyl group
and of course this one is an isobutyl
group as well so these are both these
are both ISO butyl groups now the next
thing we need to think about is how we
can number it we want to go back to our
main carbon chain which in this case is
a cycle and think about how we want a
number and the convention is is to start
numbering at the thing that is first in
alphabetical order and we consider
alphabetical order we think even the
Sein cyclo and we think of the I &
isobutyl if this was dirt or SEC you
wouldn't think about the T or the s and
sec beetle or tert-butyl but for
isobutyl you do consider the i for the
cyclos you consider the c and so when
you look at it that way all of the C's
come before the eyes and then amongst
the C's these all have cyclos but the
cyclo beautiful propyl or cyclooctane B
comes before P or O so the thing that is
first alphabetically are both of these
both of these cyclobutane start
numbering we can start numbering at
where either of them attached to the
main carbon backbone but we have to we
have to or what those are I guess we
should say those are both options but we
want a number from the one that is going
to give us the total lowest numbering so
let's think about that a little bit so
we could say let's number from here
let's make this the one carbon and so
that we hit something else as soon as
possible because remember we're trying
to minimize the numbers here we might
want to go clockwise so we hit a 2 right
over here 3 4 5 6 7 so in this situation
where do we hit interesting things we
hit interesting things at the one at the
2 or where do we have groups attach the
chain 1 to 4
four six and seven so that's one option
we'll have things groups attach it one
two four six and seven if we start right
over there and if we were to go
clockwise
our other option one two four six seven
our other option is to start it let me
erase those our other option is to start
at this other cyclobutadiene whole group
here on the left let me erase these so I
don't mess up the diagram too much the
other option is to start here make this
the one number this is one and then we
would also go clockwise to hit those
cyclopropyl as soon as quickly is to hit
something else as soon as possible so
two three four five six seven so now
where are we hitting interesting things
we have groups at the one carbon the two
carbon the four carbon the five carbon
and the seven carbon and the seven
carbon so actually this second numbering
is preferable both of them have
something at the 1 the 2 the 4 and the 7
but the second one has something at a 5
while the first one had something at a 6
so we would actually want to do this
numbering right over here and this is
the numbering that we now have on our
that we have that we have now listed
right over here let's now write what the
name of this molecule actually is so
once again we start first in
alphabetical order
so we're going to start with the cyclo
butane and one at the four carbon so we
could say 1 comma 4 and since there are
2 cyclobutadiene
1 4 die cyclo butane
what comes next in alphabetical order is
the cyclopropyl that comes before
isobutyl C comes before I that's at the
2 carbon so then we can say 2 2 cyclo
propyl 2 cyclo
propo and now we can get to the two
isobutyl x' so there's an isobutyl at
the five carbon and at the seven carbon
so we can say we can say five seven and
since there's two of them we'd say dye
isobutyl five seven dye dye isobutyl so
dye I so beYOU dye isobutyl and then we
just give the name of the backbone we've
tackled we've done the beutel's the dye
cyclobutadiene the two isobutyl x' and
now we just write cyclooctane cyclo
cyclooctane cyclooctane and we are done
we have named successfully named the
molecule and this was kind of fun it's
like a it's like a secret code or
something you wouldn't expect doing
naming organic molecules to be I think
quite so satisfying but what it is